[Music]
cheryl you look good
thank you i walked in the room and i'm
trying to date kevin so if you know
anybody you're trying to date yes i am
what is the perfect man perfect man he
got to know the lord somebody got to be
talking to god on our behalf with me
right yes um can you please have your
own
life money you know
if you run a gas station i'm cool with
it why because i'm getting good gas
prices and i'm running up in them snacks
you love some good snacks huh you don't
listen
i got a foot tank of gas and a honey bun
i sense there are men out there want to
slide into your dms
what
your dms
that sound nasty
i'm old scooby
ugh you can't just be sliding up in
nothing it's not like the big wheel
spinner you can't just slide in the sun
you got to take me out to eat or
something i go to church once or twice
or something take one look and it's
clear this comedian and host had her hot
girl summer how well we teamed up with
cheryl and metamucil for this tip on how
to kick off your journey to a healthier
lifestyle what you doing what are you
doing because you look good well okay
it's the metamucil two-week challenge so
you put metamucil into your diet for 14
days every day right and what metamucil
does for me i was feeling like sluggish
you know weighed down and it got the
waste out of me and i was i felt lighter
and more energetic where should i go to
get it started you go to metamucil.com
you sign up for the two week challenge
you'll also get tips and reminders and
you got to do it every day this is what
i really want people to understand this
is a lifestyle change make it part of
your life everyday metamucil
feel lighter and more energetic like me
you